the fact that there has been no
accountability with regards to the whole
covid debacle but the other example that
comes to mind as well is there's been no
one held accountable for the debacle
that was the withdrawal from Afghanistan
and I'm sure we could come up with a
short list very quickly of other major
disasters of zero people being held
accountable no one was held accountable
for the lies that they told around the
hunter Biden laptop uh you know we could
go down the list that that goes to the
heart of your point which is so so
important we as voters get to hold our
elected leaders accountable at The
Ballot Box right that is our primary way
of being able to make our decisions
about who we hire and fire in those
positions
it is up to us to hold their feet to the
fire to bring about that accountability
foreign
Rubin and joining me today is the host
of the Tulsi gabbard show a former U.S
congresswoman from the great state of
Hawaii and now a former Democrat Tulsi
gabbard welcome back to the Reuben
report nice to see you my friend it's
been a little while it has been a little
while Chelsea this is my first interview
of uh 2023 so you really got to bring it
today I know you're busy you're doing
your Tucker thing all the time but I
know you gotta you gotta bring it for me
can you do that uh no I'll do my best
I'll do my best
let's start real quick I don't want to
belabor the point with leaving the
Democrat Party and and you've obviously
talked about it quite a bit and I was
kind of trying to nudge you in my own
way for a while is there anything you
want to comment on related to that at
this point you left you campaigned with
some Republicans obviously the wave
didn't happen but we are seeing sort of
wholesale changes on both sides right
now
anything as we start the year off on on
that front that's on your mind
yeah sure you know I I as I think back
to uh when I announced I left the
Democratic party in October 11th and I
listed out some very specific and clear
reasons why I made that decision to
leave the Democratic party what's wrong
with today's Democratic party and my
decision to become an independent and
frankly uh the things that we have seen
play out since then and are continuing
to play out unfortunately just further
um highlight and underline those very
real concerns that I have and and
frankly since making that announcement
I've I've heard from a lot of people
um maybe some people who are well-known
names but she's also a lot of just
everyday Americans who have expressed
how they have felt or feeling the same
frustrations that I am and that
um they they were grateful to to have
somebody actually voice those uh in a
way that a lot of folks across the
country heard so you know there's a lot
happening as you know very well Dave
below the surface that doesn't make it
into you know the big headlines of the
mainstream media at all but it really is
this underlying frustration and frankly
it's not just what the Democratic party
as we're seeing happen now it's with the
Republican party as well and frankly it
points to just the American people
pissed off frustrated and
disenfranchised with those who are in
power period what was it like for you
when you because you basically made the
announcement and then you started
campaigning with some people I mean when
you were going to these rallies
obviously people people liked having you
there and all that stuff but you do have
some differences with traditional
Republicans was was there attention
there or I found there was no attention
that yeah people just get over it yeah
there was no tension and I think it was
and and sometimes those that statement
was made well we're not going to agree
on everything which which we're not who
actually does uh but but all of those
candidates that I went and supported
that none of that was planned beforehand
and uh my phone just started ringing off
the hook coming from different
candidates across the country who
recognize exactly what we just talked
about is that there are a lot of folks
who whether they identify as independent
or not are independent-minded people and
who are maybe struggling especially in
those last weeks before the election
about trying to decide who they want to
cast their vote for given their
frustrations with people in both
political parties and and so that was
that was where the requests I got came
from uh frankly it was it was
Republicans there were there were no
Democrats I think who had the courage to
even those who I know agree with my same
frustrations and concerns with the
Democratic party
um didn't have the courage to to step up
and actually say those things uh so so
the request I got came from Republicans
um across the spectrum of the Republican
party and regardless of differences on
other issues ultimately I chose to go
out and support those who value freedom
and who are committed to the
Constitution and who recognize the need
for leaders to step up and lead and
speak the truth whether that is about
leaders in the Democratic party the
Republican party but actually step up
and speak for and fight for the American
people does that seem like uh sort of an
obvious extension of the way that your
campaign when you were running for
president sort of ended in that you were
the last one besides Biden everyone else
cut the deal whatever they had to do to
get into the what would be the future
Administration you you stuck and fought
you didn't cut the deals yet Hillary
Clinton literally claiming you were in
essence a Russian operative
um so that this where you sit today as
an independent seems fairly obvious
yeah I mean I've always been an
independent-minded person
um you know for as long as I you know
chose to become a Democrat back in
2002 when I first ran for state house
here in Hawaii because at that time I
was drawn to the Democratic party
because especially here in Hawaii I saw
a party that was really rooted in uh
inclusiveness in civil liberties and
standing up for free speech and
diversity of thought and the big tent
party and and
um and frankly there were a lot of
voices in the Democratic party that were
voices for peace uh that's changed
almost wholesale since then but from
that point throughout as long as I've
been in and out of politics since 2002
I've always been an independent-minded
person always really done my best to try
to make decisions policy decisions are
otherwise based on how what what's in
the best interest of the American people
what's in the best interest of the
country so let me ask you one that's
that's actually purely on policy because
I mentioned to my locals Community this
morning learning that I was having you
on today and basically my audience loves
you even even the people that are say
more right than you are they say okay
well we can have an honest conversation
with her she's trying to talk about this
stuff all good the one that keeps coming
up with you is they still are afraid you
are going to come after their guns if
you were to go back into government that
that they see as somehow the piece of
you that is still a Democrat or
something like that I'm honestly not
even totally sure of your your policies
on on all of that so I just leave it to
you to answer the answer their question
sure uh I've always supported the Second
Amendment and the right to bear arms
what I will say has changed over the
last few years is you know previously I
you know growing up in Hawaii we uh have
one of the most restrictive laws one of
the most states with restrictive laws in
the country as it pertains to gun
ownership it takes weeks to be able to
go and apply for and get a permit and
actually be able to take the firearm
that you purchased home with you it's a
pretty it's a pretty tough and rigorous
process so I didn't grow up around you
know shooting a lot of guns in a
different culture than maybe a lot of
folks have in other parts of the country
um and so as I looked at what I felt
were Common Sense policies around uh you
know making sure that we can try to
prevent mass shootings in schools and so
forth that was what was informing my
judgment and my decision making as a
member of Congress
the thing that has changed in a very
very
impactful way for me is seeing how
the danger of this of of any one in
government
um overstepping their boundaries and
violating our rights and really
understanding in a visceral way our
Founders intent
to put the Second Amendment in place was
not only to defend your your safety and
your your family protect your family
against those who seek to do you harm
but also for us as a people as a line of
defense to protect ourselves against a
tyrannical government and when you look
at was what has happened since 2020
in so many respects we see more and more
authoritarian leaning decisions and
intentions and policies being put
forward by Our Own federal government
and you start to see again why the
Second Amendment is important that's
what I started to see and better
understand uh there are a number of
things that happened there was the
Supreme Court
decision that was made with regard to
the New York Concealed Carry Permit case
um I read actually read through a lot of
the comments and the remarks that went
on throughout that case and also the
decision and there were some things
there that uh
provided for me some some fundamental
insight and caused me to look look at
the second one in a way that frankly I'd
never had and very simply which is
um
the Second Amendment must be protected
as strongly and fiercely as we protect
the First Amendment
you don't have to get a permit to go and
I don't have to go to get a permit to go
and stand on a street corner with a
megaphone and start telling people what
I think not yet but that exactly is the
point right that exactly is the point is
we are seeing this infringement on our
right to free speech we're seeing people
in very powerful positions in our
federal government uh pointing to the
fact and questioning well I don't know
if the first amendment is relevant
anymore I don't know that it is it is
necessary and frankly people who are
even saying like it it shouldn't exist
in order to protect people from what
they call so-called hate speech or for
people being offended or whatever the
case may be and then again for me seeing
these policies these statements this
kind of
um direct undermining of our fundamental
god-given rights that are enshrined in
the Constitution further highlighted and
really brought home for me in a way that
I hadn't
um that hadn't happened for me before
with the importance of the Second
Amendment and why it says our rights
shall not be infringed is that is that
why you know when you're a guest on
Tucker or now you you fairly often guest
host that that alignment makes sense to
you because even though if you would
have said five years ago well wait a
minute here's a democratic congresswoman
from Hawaii and here's Tucker Carlson
you know basically in the Trump Camp
let's say there's a reason that it makes
sense now because so many people have
woken up to all of these infringements
on our rights like is that is that
basically the Genesis of what kind of
brings these orbits together
I think that's one of them
um I think that there are the more
people see and I think a lot of people
saw it through the covid restrictions
people who maybe weren't even involved
politically or don't really pay much
attention to a lot of things or never
watch Tucker's show or maybe yours or
didn't pay attention to me or whatever I
think more and more people were like
well hold on a second
these decisions are causing uh my family
and my community to suffer my small
business to fail and so on but it
doesn't really make sense these are not
science-based decisions these aren't
decisions that are actually respecting
our civil liberties and freedoms and
really it just got to the heart of the
fact that we had people who got a little
bit of power and decided that they
weren't going to let it go and started
abusing that power and making decisions
that were more about themselves and
their power than it was actually about
helping people and so I think I think
there were
um and are
a a number of different contributing
factors that you see people who are
frustrated by
um Corporate America abusing their power
at the expense of working people you see
um
I I think you know you see uh
impingement on religious freedom in this
country and also policies this
Administration is putting forward uh in
different parts of the world so I think
there's a lot of different factors when
people look at well hold on what what
are the fundamental principles this
country was founded upon and are those
who took an oath to support and defend
the Constitution actually fulfilling
that oath and I think people are seeing
more and more that we have Democrats and
Republicans in power in this country who
care more for themselves than they do
for the people and that's where you see
a lot of folks from across the political
Spectrum I think coming together
putting aside the political labels and
just saying hey this this is not right
and this is not what this country and
our principles are all about
is that sort of what stops you from just
saying hey I'm a republican at this
point because you just feel like it's
just like an old game so what's the
point really because most of the things
that you're saying they do line up more
with Republicans I get Republicans
usually fail on those things but at
least it's the stuff that they talk
about which really the Democrats just
simply don't talk about anymore
it's not frankly it's not something I'm
thinking about
um being an independent uh I am
continuing to do what I have been doing
which is to speak the truth and to call
it straight whether it's Democrats or
Republicans I think that there are
obviously I've been very clear in
outlining the problems that I've seen
with today's Democratic party if you
look at today's Republican party
especially what's playing out right now
on C-Span
um I think there's probably a lot of
Republicans who are asking well what is
the Republican Party stand for and like
you said uh one example is on the issue
of civil liberties there are different
factions within the Republican party
people who might say yes we stand for
freedom in the Constitution and and
civil liberties but these are the very
same people who will stand up and defend
all of the egregious uh Provisions
within the Patriot Act that undermine
our civil liberties
um we see the the you the pro war
machine uniparty in Washington Lee
leaders in both political parties
I will say there is a glimmer of hope on
the Republican Party side because unlike
the Democratic party where there
apparently are no voices now saying well
hold on we should exercise restraint we
shouldn't be going and trying to get
ourselves into new cold Wars and nuclear
armed races and nuclear war with other
countries at least on the Republican
side there's a small but growing number
of of elected leaders in Congress who
are who have the courage to stand up
against the military-industrial complex
in the war machine in Washington and
their own leaders in their own party
saying this is not good for the American
people this is not good for our country
so you know I I think I think it's it's
most important for us
to look to
holding leaders accountable from both
political parties and actually try to
bring about that that systemic change
that brings us back to uh the
Constitution not just in words but in
reality and also brings us back to what
I think is the most important premise
that our leaders should use in making
these decisions whether on domestic or
foreign policy is what is in the best
interest of the American people what is
in the best interest of ensuring the
safety security and freedom of the
American people in this country are you
worried that just too many people don't
believe that that could happen so you
know if you were to look at the 1.7
trillion dollar spending Bill and we're
going to defend the borders of Oman and
Jordan but not our own borders that at
this point there's been a certain black
pilling at least at the federal level
where people are just like it just does
not work period as I say on my show all
the time I live in Florida where
everything is highly functional and
competent and decent so I have a very
weird disconnect between my data day
life and sometimes the things that I'm
talking about on the show because here
it's freaking working maybe we can
export some of that but I think a lot of
people feel they look at a bill like
that they look at the amount of people
well I guess I'll ask it to you this way
would you have voted for that freaking
thing I would not no I would not have
voted for it there there's no question
in my mind for a whole host of reasons
but that bill is is
I think it's right that that bill and
all that it represents
um is something that is at the heart of
this whole debate around who the next
house speaker will be I think some of
the problems are that we're seeing play
out is that
um
I I don't know that the you know again
I'm not in those rooms at all I'm not
privy to private conversations at all
that are going on there but what is
being reported it doesn't seem like the
the peripheral changes that are that
they're talking about in those
negotiations are getting to kind of what
the heart of of the problem is and so
you know we'll see how that all shakes
out but I think that some of the issues
raised by people at Congressman chip Roy
are important and those are not uh
necessarily issues that are owned by
quote unquote conservatives or
Republicans I think there's a lot of
people in the country who just look at
this from a common sense perspective and
say well no it doesn't make sense for
you know Congress to pass this 1.7
trillion dollar bill that very few most
I would say didn't take the time to read
and look at and ask yeah I'm pretty sure
we can say zero you saw you've signed a
couple of these type of things right
like this thing right plus plus you get
what barely barely 72 hours like not
even working hours like 72 uh I guess
clock hours before you actually have to
vote on this thing and oh by the way
there's no open Amendment so you can't
you know as a member of Congress I would
not have been able to go in there and
say I have problems with these and these
and these provisions and then offer an
amendment on the house floor uh they
stopped allowing that a long time ago
um there's no actual open opportunity to
debate what is in the bill so it just
goes to just how broken how broken the
process is
um I think you started the question by
asking you know
is it too far gone basically right it
can't can it be fixed I think as messy
as it is what we're seeing happen play
out now with this house Speaker question
um is the kind of thing that needs to
happen in order to start bringing about
the changes that actually fix what's
wrong yeah and just for the record we're
taping this on Friday afternoon I think
they're in their 12th round right now
and a few people did switch to McCarthy
but we're posting this on Monday so Lord
Only Knows what'll happen see what
happens with the rest of the votes I
want to back up to something that you
said earlier uh was sort of about the
bureaucratic State and the people who
failed us and and did trample on our
civil liberties during covet and all
that what do you think if anything
should be done I'm not a particularly
the type of guy that wants to have
retribution against people but it seems
to me that the people that forced the
vaxes and the man and the mandates and
now we're finding out all of this stuff
about you know heart problems and a
Litany of other issues nobody's been
fired at the CDC nobody's been fired at
at HHS fauci did I guess resign in
effect but was allowed to retire right
was allowed to retire wolenski is still
wandering around the capitol like what
do should we do anything do we need to
do anything otherwise to me it's just
like we'll just endlessly we'll do it
we'll do it all over again because
nobody will have paid the price I I
agree I agree the the fact that there
has been uh no accountability with
regards to uh the whole covid debacle
but the other example that comes to mind
as well is there's been no one held
accountable for the debacle that was the
withdrawal from Afghanistan and I'm sure
we could come up with a short list very
quickly of other major disasters of zero
people being held accountable no one was
held accountable for the lies that they
told around the hunter Biden laptop uh
you know we could go down the list that
that goes to the heart of your point
which is so so important we as voters
get to hold our elected leaders
accountable at The Ballot Box right that
is our primary way of being able to make
our decisions about who we hire and fire
in those positions
it is up to us to hold their feet to the
fire to bring about that accountability
in in kind of the the uh uh you know the
security state in some elements the
bureaucratic State the administrative
State whatever whatever you want to call
it Congress plays an incredibly
important role in that with an
Administration that fails to hold its
own uh both appointed leaders
accountable as well as those who are
bureaucrats in the system this is where
the House of Representatives and the
Senate come into such a critical role
and why we have this co-equal Branch why
who we vote for in those positions
matters so that the oversight committee
can do its job so that it can bring
people in so they can establish select
committees to actually hold those
responsible accountable and with
transparency to the American people
about what they're doing why they're
doing it and frankly exposing the
dangerous situation that we have now
where we have these uh unappointed
unelected people in positions of power
making decisions changing rules within
the government they have a very real
impact on Our Lives the lives of our
kids and families and businesses across
this country but somehow they're allowed
to essentially make law through
administrative rule changes again
without any kind of legislative process
without any input on the America from
the American people through our elected
representatives do you think that some
of the other Congress people when you
were serving they kind of liked that
fact they like the fact that their
decision making was outsourced and
basically absolutely they didn't have to
do anything I mean that's yeah yeah
because because what is what what what
what answer do they have though when
they go home maybe they have a town hall
meeting or they answer their
constituency why has this happened like
oh sorry it's that guy's fault sorry
it's their fault no Wiz didn't go
through Congress it's not on our plate
but but in reality uh they're abdicating
that very essential and important
responsibility
um that that Congress has and and it has
happened over time in so many different
aspects of our government and it allows
people who we as voters elect to
basically sideline themselves because
then they carry no responsibility for
those decisions that are being made
Congress should be fighting to claw back
their own power right Congress should be
bringing trying to bring that back roll
back the power that's been given to the
executive branch to just basically do
whatever they want but unfortunately
again and this is you know who's
responsible well guess what both
Democrats and Republicans have been in
charge uh you know one way at one time
or another and we don't see that kind of
the recognizing kind of what what's the
underlying issue here and instead we see
a lot of leaders
people who are in leadership positions
just reacting and saying well we'll just
we'll just pass a new law for this pass
a new law for that but but not actually
getting to well how did we even get here
in the first place and let's get back to
the cause of the problem rather than
just throwing another Band-Aid on it so
to that point you you were one of the
most outspoken anti-war congresswoman
Congress people in the country while you
served and you paid the price for it I
mean literally again Hillary was calling
you a Russian stooge or whatever
whatever they were saying about you lit
because you were anti-war so right now
with this Ukraine situation we are not
at War Congress has not declared war but
we are funding a war to over a hundred
billion dollars at this point another 40
billion just in the in the 1.7 trillion
dollar bill we're funding the war we're
giving weapons we're giving intelligence
we're training soldiers to me that kind
of sounds like we're at War uh it
essentially is a proxy war and this is a
yet another way that this Administration
and Congress Democrat and republicans in
Congress have once again bypassed their
constitutional responsibility if they
want to go to war with Russia which
they've made very clear that that is
what they want both directly and
verbally and also indirectly through
their actions
make your case make your case to the
American people about why you feel that
that is so important why they feel it is
in the best interest of our country and
the American people and why the American
people should be willing to pay the
price for it as you said it's already
over a hundred billion dollars meanwhile
you look at a lot of folks who are still
struggling and suffering uh here at home
both those who have been impacted by
natural disasters those in Mississippi
for example who are still under a boiled
water policy because they don't have
access to clean drinking water that they
can use for their families I mean there
are so many basic basic challenges here
that we are too often told we just we
just can't afford it we don't have the
money for it and yet we the the people
have had no say in this hundred billion
dollars that's gone over to fund this
proxy war uh with Russia via Ukraine
what to speak of the suffering of the
Ukrainian people
um
so so what do we do I think is is the
big question right at this point because
we all have great compassion for the
people of Ukraine uh what Putin did is
wrong absolutely wrong in invading
Ukraine these are not disputable things
the problem is that you we have
politicians in Washington and the Biden
Administration as well as in Congress
who even though they say they care for
the people of Ukraine are not doing what
is necessary to bring about an end to
this war instead seeking to escalate it
further and further and doing so uh
through their actions which again really
just shows their true motives true
intentions uh which is is feeding into
the military-industrial complex uh it's
not about bringing about peace because
if it were all the way back in February
and in March and in subsequent months
since they would have been supporting a
peace process rather than actively
trying to block pocket were you shocked
when zielinski gave that speech to
Congress a couple weeks ago and and in
essence said there will be no compromise
I mean it's a little odd to say and I
agree with you on the first off we at
locals we had an office in Ukraine we
had to move our guys out we've gotten
some of them to the United States but
some of them are in Macedonia right now
like I have complete sympathy for
everyone there but the guy that's in the
war shows up here and says I will not
compromise with the guy with nukes and
everyone applaud it it's like do you
know what happens when the guy with
nukes thinks he's losing
exactly exactly
um there there was so much that was
deeply disturbing about that speech and
how most members of Congress reacted
with Applause with adoration
um
treating him as though he is some some
hero or or rock star I think one of the
things that in addition to the point
that you mentioned about about we have
actively and and I I hold our leaders
responsible zelinski is going to do what
zelinski is going to do but I hold our
leaders responsible President Biden
Democrat Republican leaders in Congress
responsible for the decisions that they
have made that have put the American
people in our country at risk by
escalating this war against a
nuclear-armed power pushing us to the
brink of nuclear catastrophe with no
with no plan with no investment saying
okay well here we are good thing we went
and invested trillions of dollars in
underground bunkers for every American
citizen to go and take shelter because
we've put you in this situation they've
not done that at all if anything they've
done it for themselves but not for the
American people which leaves which
leaves us in a position of of Parish in
that scenario but the other thing in
addition to that that was so disturbing
about his speech was
how he spoke about freedom and he spoke
about democracy and he's not only
putting himself in the position as being
this champion of democracy around the
world but our own leaders have lionized
him and made this whole War about well
we have to defend democracy and freedom
in Ukraine or else democracy and freedom
in the world will be assaulted or or
attacked well let's look at what uh kind
of democracy zielinski is leading in
Ukraine you know he not only jailed his
political opponents very very very early
on he banned their entire political
party
um you know there are so many different
you know he shut down any media that was
not controlled by him and his government
essentially so no free speech uh no no
room for any political opposition
and then he went after uh religion no
religious freedom in this country he
shut down the second largest Christian
Church in that country uh and for for
what under the guise of democracy and
freedom how how is this representative
of of the kind of democracy that that
our Founders envisioned it doesn't and
so what what I what I reflected on what
I think every American should think
about is they watch this this is the guy
they have put as the figurehead of
democracy and we saw Republicans and
Democrats cheering and applauding for
this person uh who doesn't believe in
free speech doesn't believe in freedom
of religion doesn't believe in Freedom
or democracy really at all
and so we should not therefore then be
surprised if this is what they believe
democracy is
then we shouldn't be surprised at the
kinds of things that they're doing to
undermine our own freedoms here at home
and our own uh democracy here at home
because it's it's happening it's not a
question at this point and this should
be this should be alarming uh for
everybody and not surprising that this
is the the direction that they're that
they're taking which is not
representative democracy at all it's
more representative of a dictatorship or
an authoritarian government yeah and the
funny part is I don't blame zielinski
for coming here and demanding money and
demanding no compromise because why the
hell not and then you walk away with
everything you asked for so he's doing
what's what he believes is right for
himself or his party or his country and
you've got a bunch of people here that
are like oh how much can I write on that
check and exactly yeah exactly and and
that's that's the thing that that's so
crazy to me I even after that speech I
think it was a couple of days ago there
was a story that popped up where
zielinski was was basically saying that
his quote-unquote allies have no excuse
not to to send him these light armored
vehicles there's no excuse why they
aren't just sending him exactly every
single thing that he demands
that's crazy to me and it's crazy what's
even crazier than his demands though is
he knows what power he has because he
has the most powerful people in the
United States of America bowing to him
and giving him whatever he wants and
President Biden essentially seeding our
country's foreign policy decisions to
this guy
in Ukraine
um you know what when people ask the
president well when when does this war
end when do we stop when is enough
enough and he says well well you know
we're in it why I don't I'm not going to
quote him directly because I don't have
the quote but he basically has said
we'll do whatever it takes we're in this
until what this is up to Putin to decide
like what what about your leadership
your responsibility as the president
United States what about the leadership
of of the head of the house the head of
the Senate from both political parties
where is their leadership and their
responsibility coming to play because
they are certainly not serving the best
interests of the American people our
security and our country with these
decisions so with that in mind if we
were to flash back to say you know what
is it about six years ago we sat down
for the first time at my house in La
when you were running it was just at the
beginning of the time and it seems like
it seems like many lifetimes ago right
yeah it's many states ago for me
um you you were obviously frustrated
with the squad and I think you were one
of the first at least sitting Democrats
to talk about that publicly like a lot
of a lot of online people were talking
about it but you were frustrated with
that but then that thing ran went
rampant throughout the party do you
think there's any who like is there any
calm voice there that's saying anything
that makes sense to to Biden or Kamala
or it's just it just is gone now it's a
good question I don't know really
frankly I don't know
um I don't know I I know that there are
people there who uh who I worked with
before who take a more common sense
approach
um and who are concerned about a lot of
the same things that I'm concerned about
but whether or not they actually uh
whether or not they have fallen into
that same wave of so-called wokism or
what and whether or not they actually
have the courage to have these
conversations even in private even if
they're not willing to say these things
in public even in private
um I don't I don't know but what we do
know is how they are carrying themselves
publicly the things they are saying
publicly and the decisions that they are
making in the votes that they cast and
the fact that we don't have people in
the Democratic party today who uh are
speaking out against things like
infringing on Free Speech
standing up for free speech is not a
thing in the Democratic party anymore
today or if you say something that is
offensive to anybody then you shouldn't
be allowed to say it which is just
Insanity uh you know I don't know if
you've had Ira Glasser on your show but
he as the former head of the ACLU for
decades and who's somebody who considers
himself a very left Progressive person
is to me the lone voice that I've heard
in those political circles who is
calling out this Insanity for for what
it is because he's literally lived
through it and he's seen what happens
when you carry through uh when you carry
out some of the policies that are or the
the proposals that they're putting
forward that actually limit our first
amendment rights and and unfortunately
those voices are very very rare yeah I
actually I haven't had him on but I had
his predecessor I think was Nadine
strassen and when I had her on she
talked about how the ACLU used to defend
the rights I know you know this the
defend the rights of Nazis to march in
Skokie Illinois where they had more
Holocaust Survivors than anywhere in the
United States that was once the ACLU the
defender of free speech so that that's
actually a good segue to the big Tech
stuff because you've been fighting the
big Tech stuff for a long time and
actually during your campaign I think
you were in a lawsuit with Google at the
time yeah
um so a did did anything come of that
and B then just broadly like Twitter
files the whole freaking thing what what
is going on here full freaking thing
yeah uh judge a judge throughout so so
for those who don't know
um I filed a lawsuit against Google
because frankly of their interference in
our elections through my campaign
something that I experienced personally
when I was first running for president I
knew there was not there were a lot of
people in this country who didn't know
who I was and I hoped that you know by
going and standing on the presidential
debate stage as people would see uh hey
who's this person she might be saying
some interesting things how do we find
out more about her so we set up a Google
ads account uh in the hopes that people
would start looking to try to get more
information about why I was offering to
serve as president well that happened I
was the most searched candidate in that
first debate and in subsequent debates
after but in that first debate what
ended up happening afterwards is Google
suspended our ad account without any
explanation without any warning our Tech
Team obviously got on it right away and
they were trying to figure okay what did
what did we do wrong how do we fix this
how do we bring this account back up so
it's not suspended anymore didn't get a
response and then I I don't know how
long it was later but finally the
account was reinstated without any
explanation whatsoever so obviously this
had a very negative impact on what I was
trying to accomplish in my campaign and
being able to reach people but we filed
a lawsuit for the deeper issue which was
if Google can make this decision single
handling whether it was somebody sitting
at a small desk somewhere just making
that decision themselves or if it was
people people at a higher up level it
doesn't really matter the point is that
you have this Monopoly in this major
massive tech company that has the
ability to interfere with the
information that voters are seeking to
get about so that they can make a
decision about who they want to vote for
and the most important office in this
country the most powerful office in this
country and so if they could do that to
a sitting member of Congress running for
president United States just imagine
what they could do to anyone anywhere
for any reason to serve their own
interest and so that was the Crux of the
lawsuit we filed the lawsuit a judge
tossed it out
but as we have seen now in those years
since there have been more and more
Revelations coming from and about these
different big tech companies how they
have directly sought to undermine and
interfere frankly in in our democracy
what to speak of all the censorship
stuff that that's a whole other parallel
conversation so when you see the Twitter
files get dumped and now you've already
gone through this as you just laid out
kudos to Elon Musk for that right
absolutely absolutely I mean here's one
guy all he's saying is hey free speech
and of course now we're watching the
entire machine call them a white
supremacist and God knows what else
they're they're saying about the guy but
when when you watch all of this get
exposed it's is this another case of
okay well a certain amount of us that
have believed this stuff was happening
now are strengthened in our view but
that the rest of the machine just
ignores it so we we showed something on
on the show last week about how ABC NBC
and C PBS Nightly News in the first week
of Twitter files did literally zero
coverage and then over the course then
they added in some cable news channels
except for Fox and it turned out to be
like 17 minutes you know over the course
of two weeks something like that but
leading to this just sort of bifurcation
of the populace where I can't blame all
those people who don't know what they
don't see because they they have no idea
what they don't say
that is exactly the whole problem I
think I think there's a number of things
first of all new media platforms are
becoming more popular and more important
especially as people are are maybe even
if they they don't know what they don't
know but I think that most people are
recognizing that they can't trust what
they're being told on these mainstream
media platforms and so for those who
have time and interest they're able to
look for other news sources and and it's
awesome to see how New Media is growing
and providing really substantive
platforms that that can help feed that
desire for real information for truth or
frankly a different you know differing
opinions the real dialogue and
conversation I think we also again have
to look to Congress look to the power
that big Tech has it's not by accident
you look at how much money big Tech
dishes to both Republican and Democrat
leaders in Washington you can very
clearly connect the dots about why
Congress has not done anything at all
frankly to be able to rein in these
monopolies that exist in big Tech that
directly undermine our democracy and
directly interfere in our own elections
I think those are kind of the two places
that that we start with
do you all right so
assuming that maybe we do some of that
is but do you think it just ends up as
another one of the what we talked about
before like just nothing changes because
the machine operates in a certain way
right like I guess I guess you know you
can see I've been like slightly taking
this black pill at the federal level
lately life is good in Florida but I
definitely have taken that you know at
some to some extent I get it I get it I
um I remain hopeful Dave I remain
hopeful and I refuse to accept good I
want hope I want hope we need it yeah I
refuse to accept that this broken system
is just the way it will be and that we
the American people have to accept
failure
um the system is broken it does need to
be fixed there are wholesale changes
that need to be made but I remain
hopeful that the more people who learn
about this the more voices there are
that are speaking the truth the more
voices there are lifting up the message
of of how important our god-given
freedoms are in the Constitution that we
have to stand up against those who seek
to try to undermine them and take them
away uh we the people in this Democratic
Republic have an immense amount of power
if we choose to use it both at The
Ballot Box and with our voices we saw
unfortunate fortunately again how many
people did not show up to vote on
election day in November that that's a
travesty if we're not showing up if
we're not invested in our own future
then how can we ex how can we expect
anything really to be fixed or changed
and we'll see the same most powerful
most wealthy people continuing to run
the show not for us or our benefit but
for their own so as we see that split in
like in the reality that people are
experiencing we're also seeing a split
in where people are living you know
something like 500 000 people since
covet I mean it's a crazy number have
left California Florida has an influx
now of almost 400 000. New York has lost
about 300 000. Texas gained we're just
seeing this movement happening
um you happen to live in a place that is
separate geographically so yeah Hawaii
even if it's you know it can be a little
tough there sometimes I guess with some
of the politics it's like you got the
waves I know you're doing okay over
there but what do you make make of this
sort of geographic shift that's
happening across the country because
ultimately it obviously will make the
red States redder and the blue States
Bluer I mean hochul only won by Five
Points hokel whatever her name is only
five points in New York but if you
factor in about 350 000 people that left
New York it's like wow it maybe could
have gone red
yeah
yeah I I think it shows that again
through the last few years uh how much
state government and Leadership has an
impact and you're seeing that kind of
Exodus and movement happening and I
think it points to kind of one of the
bigger changes that I think will even be
harder than some of the ones we're
talking about but that needs to happen
which is the federal government needs to
go back to what our Founders envisioned
as being uh fulfilling the response The
Limited responsibilities of the federal
government and empowering states to lead
uh and and Implement their own policies
at the state level because every one of
our states is very very different in so
many ways that was the the uh picture of
this country that our Founders
envisioned but unfortunately at the
federal level there has been just over
time more and more of uh overreach and
Stranglehold on power uh disempowering
the states and so hopefully with some of
these changes people are recognizing
more that that responsibility at the
state level uh is where is where those
decisions really need to be made in in
so many respects and frankly a lot of
Governors also we've seen over the last
few years standing up and saying no
federal government we're not going to do
exactly what you tell us to we're not
going to just bend the knee and comply
we will uphold though that we took to to
fulfill their responsibility to the
people of their state as well which I
think is encouraging so I take it when
you see a guy like Ron DeSantis keeping
the state open and getting woke stuff
out of schools and from at least where I
sit you know pretty much doing
everything right that that's the type of
marker you have for Hope then
I think I think I I'm not tracking
everything happening in Florida politics
but I think some of the decisions that
we've seen played out nationally that he
has made for Florida it shows that you
know he's he's making the decisions that
he feels are best uh for the people of
Florida and a lot of people are moving
there so it seems to be working so you
know I have to ask you about the future
what's the deal are you enjoying these
uh I think the Audio I can't hear it
I can tell clearly that you're enjoying
the the stuff you're doing with Tucker
when you're guest hosting it's just it
comes across on television like you
really are enjoying it obviously and
you're doing your podcast and obviously
you're speaking and you're doing some
campaign stuff when it when it arrives
but do you want to get back into the
machine are you relieved to not be part
of that right now is it all way too
early is it just the most annoying
question on Earth
well it's not the most annoying question
it's just it's just one that I don't I
don't have an answer to frankly uh to me
the question is not about well do I want
to get back into politics or not because
I I have never thought in my mind like
oh I'm setting out on a political career
that's never been a factor for me the
the question for me that I've always uh
had and and continue to reflect on and
try to answer is where and how can I
best be of service
that's my goal and so whether that ends
up being in an elected political
position or if it ends up being in a
position where uh now I'm trying to use
my voice and whatever platforms I have
available to me to be a voice for for
truth and Common Sense and freedom in
this country when a lot of people are
afraid to speak the truth a lot of
people are not focusing on on or maybe
don't know about what is actually
happening in our country that's
undermining our freedom so so that that
really is the answer to what happens
next for me do I get you know run for
office again or not is is I I don't know
the answer to that uh I will continue to
seek to to best to be where I can best
be of service and make a positive impact
for
um the American people in this country
Tulsi you continue to be on my very
short list of sane people I wish it was
a longer list but you're on the short
list I'd like to see your short list of
same people I hope I hope I'm on that
list of course of course and it is
unfortunately it's it's unfortunately a
short list of of known people but I I
know that we are in good company of
people across this country who may not
have a show themselves uh but who are
hungry for and yearning for some common
sense
courageous leadership in this country
and and that that is what we desperately
need on that note I welcome you to the
free state of Florida whenever you want
to come I know our way our waves are not
as good that's the thing I'll be there
and I'll be there in February actually
I'll I'll send you my dates and
hopefully we can hang out a little bit
dinner on me it was good seeing you all
right sounds good thanks Dave if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
mindless dribble check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell